bonjour et bienvenue sur dia gonal tv
grand champion d'échecs aujourd'hui avec
jérôme on fera ça le jir homme s'est mis
stephen âmes aujourd'hui on va voir un
des grands champions d'après guerre
russe david bernstein
oui david bernstein qui est russe en
tout cas qui est né dans l' empire dans
leur part en union soviétique puisqu'il
est né en 1924 pour parler dans le
berceau demande y est on peut pas rater
d'empyr soviétique
il est près de kiev en fait en ukraine
et donc n'est pas russe un pur russe qui
plus est il est même juif il est né dans
une famille juive comme beaucoup de
joueurs d'échecs d'ailleurs de l'école
soviétique et il a fait partie de cette
petite élite
deux ukrainiennes son père était
dirigeant d'entreprise mais diriger une
petite minoterie et donc il faisait
partie des petits bourgeois de l'est
l'ukraine d'alors d'accord
et alors donc comment il comme l a fait
sa carrière comment ça s'est passé
ben en fait c'est parents s'occupaient
de lui bien sûr mais il ya aussi son
grand père qui s'est occupé de lui qui
lui a transmis un précieux héritage
puisqu'il lui a appris à jouer aux
échecs et 6 ans donc assez assez jeune
c'est relâche fréquent pour les
champions 5-6 ans on voit souvent les
champions débuté à cet âge là ouais donc
le jeune david borenstein joue un petit
peu comme ça et puis je suis comme une
montre quelques dispositions on lui fait
donner des cours
parent quant à m à mettre de leningrad
qui s'appelle constituant de constantine
open skies d'accord donc là des coups il
progresse vite et progresse très vite et
on pense qu'il va avoir une carrière
fulgurante mais il est né en 1924 et il
a une quinzaine d'années en 1939 énorme
problème bien sûr puisque tu le sais
l'ukraine est le grenier à blé de
l'europe
et quand les nazis envahissent l'urss
il se dirige bien sûr vers le sud vers
l'ukraine et aussi vers le pétrole de
bessarabie et de fait la famille
bronstein est obligé de s'enfuir et sur
le nom à consonance juive de bronstein
rendre les choses encore plus encore
plus compliqué donc la famille est
obligé de s'enfuir en 1900 1941 le père
de
david bronstein mêmes mêmes déportés au
goulag parce que justement il est juif
et même en union soviétique il ya quand
même un peu d'antisémitisme il est aussi
déportés parce que en définitive c'est
un c'est un patron il était dirigeant
d'une minoterie donc de toute façon il
était un peu considérée comme un ennemi
politique du origine une certaine phase
d'accord donc le jeune bronstein voit sa
carrière interrompue pendant toutes ces
années et à la fin de la guerre il est
assez révolté par ce qui est arrivé à sa
famille notamment à son père qui a été
déporté et il va conserver un caractère
assez rebelle notamment vis-à-vis des du
régime soviétique
à cette période donc il a fait ensuite
des études est allé à l'école
polytechnique de leningrad et à
continuer en parallèle sa carrière de
joueur d'échecs
donc c'est en parallèle donc il a quand
même gardé une activité à côté de sang
oui comme beaucoup de communes charger
bobigny qui était ingénieur beaucoup de
joueurs d'échecs soviétiques ont fait
des études en ingénierie ou dans les
sciences une manière générale et donc
c'est après guerre en fait qui va
obtenir ce meilleur résultat oui il
obtient ses meilleurs résultats dans
l'immédiate après guerre puisque c'est
la partie qu'on va voir je crois il
arrive à se qualifier à l'international
plus automnales et finalement après un
match de
départage contre volley cev ski un de
ses meilleurs amis il avait qualifié
pour la finale du championnat du monde
qui va jouer contre bobigny qu bobigny
que lui mais bon il faut noter à ce
moment là qui est devenu champion du
monde en ayant gagné lui un tournoi en
fait oui puisque ali qui n'était
champion du monde au moment où la
seconde guerre mondiale a éclaté
la mort d'alexis né en 1946 n'a pas
permis d'organiser le match aller
kinbote unique que souhaitaient les
autorités soviétiques puisque les kinés
temps à russes blancs exilé en france
qui plus est plus ou moins de mêlée à la
collaboration les soviétiques vous
révèle ce match entre bobigny qu est
allé keane pour punir a liquidé ses
multiples trahison envers le régime
soviétique
ils n'ont pas pu les îles ont pas pu
l'organiser de fait la fédération
internationale a organisé un tournoi
avec les meilleurs joueurs de l'époque
en 1948 qui a été remporté par bobigny
qui essaient depuis quarante-huit qu'il
est champion du monde et il doit
défendre son titre en 1951 puisque le
cycle de championnat du monde dure trois
ans et à leur poste ce tournoi qui est
dû à la mort d'ali keynes est le seul
intermède de des championnats du monde
classique où il ya une coupure et on
décide en tournoi pour pour élire en
quelque 100 femmes pourront avoir un
nouveau champion du monde et le premier
match ensuite pour mes renouveau du
match mais cette fois par qualification
larguerait organisé alors qu'avant
c'était plutôt par bourse vous là les
guînes c'était quand même celui qui
paient le plus qui pouvait jouer un
petit peu comme à la boxe où il y avait
quelque chose comme ça voilà et là c'est
devenu un peu plus
un peu plus je dirais formelle un peu
plus un peu plus légitime et finalement
je tenais le premier véritable candidats
qualifiés quoi en fait voilà dans
l'histoire du jeu de l'histoire du jeu
dans tout ce qu'on va appeler la période
classique des championnats du monde
c'est le premier match de championnat du
monde en 24 parties tels qu'on les a
connus jusque dans les années 80 oui
c'est vrai en 24 parties à l'époque déjà
donc des matchs loin c'était sur
plusieurs mois à ce jour au moins deux
ou trois quatre mois des fois même
surtout que là encore c'était oui avec
la partie déjà c'était pas les parties
illimitées qu'on ya eu un peu plus tard
un non non non non non c'était 24
parties le champion en titre gardant son
titre en cas de match nul 12 partout
grâce à l'importance d'accord et alors
après la fin de sa carrière il continue
à être un très fort joueur mais il
revient plus aussi au niveau du
changement il ya il n'aura plus
l'occasion nouveau d'approcher la
couronne mondiale il va se faire
connaître et rester dans l'histoire bien
sûr par ces partis par ses nombreuses
victoires en tournoi mais aussi par des
livres comme l'apprenti sorcier oui
c'est le surnom qu'on lui a conclu que
la postérité lui a laissé oui comme il y
avait un talent que c'était le magicien
voilà par le sorcier magicien
effectivement des noms les dialogues et
de beaucoup pour kasparov il ya un petit
qu'on nomma diaspora l'inde dont la lui
c'était l'apprenti sorcier
l'apprenti sorcier et l'art du combat
aussi alors là tout l'art du combat de
l'échec est aussi un grand best-seller
aux échecs donc un peu ardue comme lille
quand même parce qu'il est parti un peu
austère de l'époque mais qui retrace
tout un tournoi
or c'est toi de zurich en 1953 et toutes
les parties du tournoi sont reprises
dans l sont pas toutes commentées sont
parfois sèche peut te faut les regarder
tel quel mais il y avait le plus grand
joueur de l'époque déjà
oui ils étaient tous là donc c'était
quand même c'était le summum de ce qu'on
pouvait espérer à l'époque en tant que
tournoi ces deux double rang non plus
donc c'est lourd c'est quand même un
gros livre bien lourd c'est un gros
livre avec quelques parties commentées
mais ccc ccc faut vraiment avoir envie
de travailler les échecs pour pour ce
livre là mais c'est vrai que c'est ces
riches mais bon c'est resté un terrain
best seller en urss c'est un livre qui
s'est beaucoup vendu qui a été beaucoup
utilisé toujours réédité gédé ouais mais
qui restait bien sûr qui est resté un
classique du genre
c'est vrai même si c'est vrai que
c'était parti d'une époque c'est pas
faux s'est pas départi romantique on est
dans des échecs un peu plus scientifique
un petit peu plus calculé que dans la
période des années 20 ou 30
voilà ils ont connecté partie
intéressante quand même tout à fait oui
dont il faut le lire en chaire faut
moins l'avoir perçue faut regarder il
faut voir comment les échecs étaient
joués avant que finalement le dynamisme
l'emportent parce que c'est à partir de
fisher finalement et ensuite ça a été
mis vraiment au sommet par kasparov où
la notion de dynamisme aux échecs a pris
le pas sur la notion un peu plus je
dirais positionnait les matérialistes
aussi ou donc c'était plutôt ça s'est
joué après sur le fil du rasoir alors
que là c'était pas que c'était quand
même un jeu ne peut trancher quoi c'est
un peu lourd mais on verra un peu dans
la partie c'est c'est une espèce
d'écrasement positionnelle bien dans le
style de l'époque et il a fallu cathala
rim finaland pour pour remettre au goût
du jour la tactique et le la suprématie
du calcul pure sur le sur le pouce sur
la position
alors donc l'apprenti sorcier donc on a
vu ces données donc un jour important
joueur qu'il y a quand même joué
une finale de championnat du maroc est
marié et qui a été assez dantesques
cette finale de championnat du monde
avec avec des parties très très acharné
souvent longues et le déroulement du
match au fait que bronstein a réussi à
prendre l'aventage dans la toute fin du
match
22e parti et à ce moment là il a un
point d'avancé sur le champion du monde
donc deux parties nulles lui suffisent
pour être champion du monde
et malheureusement pour lui le père et
votre vie ni que le rejoint et fini par
garder son titre
ouais scène partout willan victoire
chanel sa victoire qu'elle apprenne
émanerait de partie les nuls étant
comptée comme les demi point et en
définitive il l'a planer des doutes sur
le fait que bronstein est perdue alors
qu'elle fait preuve d'une grande
solidité qu'il ait perdu la partie
décisive qui a permis à bobigny qu de le
rejoindre sur le fil
il a confié dans l'apprenti sorcier
qu'effectivement il ya eu des pressions
et que c'était en définitive à lui de de
ne pas les ressentir
ouais ce de façon un petit peu laconique
les pressions politiques coin des
pressions politiques
on raconte que dans les années 60 alors
que fisher venait de perdre une partie
contre spassky et qu'il était en pleurs
bronstein est allé le consoler en lui
disant mais tu as perdu mais toi t'as
pas obligés à perdre fermez le ban le
mystère reste entier
est ce que c'est une façon de distiller
un petit peu de légende ou de laisser
accroire que il aurait pu être champion
du monde si on en avait pas empêché
c'est possible toujours est il que il a
véritablement été tout près d'être
champion du monde
jusqu'à cornouailles ont considéré que
c'était le plus fort joueur du monde à
ne pas là pas ne pas avoir été champion
du monde donc c'est un joueur important
des années des années 50-60 pour pour
cela et on va voir effectivement dans
cette partie
comment il arrive à battre le champion
du monde en titre oui alors avant
d'arriver à la partie on va regarder
quelques photos
david bernstein voilà j'aime pas
beaucoup en avoir deux alors donc ça
c'est donc cc david bretagne ou encore
avec des lunettes est toujours eu des
mines est même avec des gros yeux
ouverts je crois qu'il avait des points
de vue il
il avait des problèmes de jusque qui lui
a permis d'éviter en partie les combats
de la guerre puisqu'il avait l'âge
d'être mobilisés mais en fait en dehors
à cause de sa mauvaise vue il a été jugé
inapte et il a été affecté à la
reconstruction des immeubles détruits
par les allemands d'accord et revoilà la
deuxième photo c c'est alors c'est bon
je t'aime aussi mais non c'est pas une
photo de lui vivant c'est simplement
voilà son s'attendre avec son épitaphe
avec on voit bien d'ailleurs
signe symbolique échiquéenne c'est le
conserver en kabylie et le surmontée
d'une couronne de dames en fait donc on
va bien voilà l'idée qu'il est mort
récemment
bon je t'aime bien on voit bien 2005
donc il est mort il n'ya pas longtemps
puisqu'on a enregistré l'émission 2012
1924 au moins ça date de 2005 80 81 ans
travaille pour revenir en un mot aussi
soit difficultés qu'il a eu avec le
régime soviétique dès sa plus tendre
enfance dès sa jeunesse faut rappeler
que le véritable nom de trotski lycée
bronstein et que trotsky était le grand
ennemi de staline a une vraie et en
maintenant le trotski séville david lee
jones ils étaient parents du tout du
tout beaucoup de bernstein en urss
d'accord mais le fait est qu'ils
portaient le nom
les unit jurés du régime stalinien l'anc
ça n'a pas forcément aidés dacoury dans
sa carrière ni dans sa vie quotidienne
voilà donc on va revenir sur le plateau
et on va ensuite passer sur notre parti
du jour donc de david bronstein pour lui
rendre hommage évidemment et c'est une
de ces victoires au championnat du monde
face à votre vie ni d'ailleurs c'est la
partie sa dernière victoire donc il lui
donnait presque le titre et qui était
vraiment très très proche de la fin qui
a fait de moi je tiens la légende qui
dit aujourd'hui du jeu d'échecs donc ici
bobigny qu.aller blanc donc on va
regarder la partie du côté noir c'est
mieux on se met du côté de notre
champion du jour face à david prochains
championnats du monde 1951 et c'est
parti avec des quatre donc coup du pion
de la dame début fermez donc cavalier f6
c4 donc là jusqu'ici des coups normaux
donc les blancs occupent le centre les
blancs les noirs alors là maintenant les
noix en plein de choix on peut jouer
j'ai si ils ont peu joué aussi son peut
jouer pourquoi passer si son fils à nos
simulations beaucoup que c'était
possible d 4d quand même le coup de
bobigny qui dans les années 50 de
manière générale les blancs je n'en peux
plus des quatre que quatre points c'est
vrai c'est vrai tout à fait mais il
n'était pas trouvée dans les débuts
ouvert c'est un peu le les années ces
années 50 sont plus le contre-pied du
19e siècle où ils s'étaient que dès le 4
ans quelques des productions du roi on
était justement beaucoup plus c'était
des compositions beaucoup la possible le
positionnait l'emporté sur le tapis
qu'il fallait jouer le positionnait il
faut vraiment attendre fischer pour
revoir le 4
fischer diviser les gens qui ne jouent
pas eu quatre sondés
puissance des poumons sont follement il
y aurait donc aussi ce prêt je joue pas
je vous paierai 4 donc alors eu six donc
classique alors l'idée 2,6 ce soit de
jouer dès 5 ans rentre dans une combi
l'âme pourquoi pas ou plus fréquemment
d'essayer de jouer food et 4 avec ce
qu'on appelle une ouest viennent donc
loi jeu de l'éventuelle qu'avec des
citrons ici donc laissé trois ils font
des crânes voilà donc c'est l'idée alors
pourquoi on joue full méca parce que
lecavalier c3 contrôle 4,1 des plans des
blancs simple c'est d'en devenir le
centre en jouant sous b 4 eh bien on
empêche cette poussée puisqu'il suffit
de prendre le cavalier ne peut pas
puisque il y aura échec en ce qu'on
appelle un clouage voilà ce fou
immobilise le cas wc3 et donc ne permet
pas aux blancs de contrôler la case de 4
donc c'est logique 1 tout est logique
donc ici il ya plein de possibilités
pour les blancs mais c'est trois choisis
par mode unie très solide alors le
problème de 3 alors l'avantagé c'est que
trois bons mais on se prépare à la
sortie du fou est par contre on boit en
bloc pour l'instant l'avenir du fou
c'est un bon peut-être que plus tard les
blancs pour un joueur 4 libéré se fout
ou peut-être que ce fou plus tard pourra
se sortir du côté de la halle dame
faudra jouer des trois fonds des 2 ou 3
3 mais il faudra d'abord résoudre le
problème du clonage ici donc tout ceci
est normal mais c'est c'est pas voilà
c'est pas violemment agressif n'ont
cessé c'est à dire attentiste mais on
n'en est pas là on ne sait pas danser
positionne lcc attention il ya quand
même il s'est beaucoup donné dans ces
petits de position ça celui toujours
donc il faut être très attentif
alors b6 toujours l'idée de fouler 4 ses
classiques on a mis encore apple en bloc
le cavalier ici pour l'empêcher de
contrôler la quasi si puisqu'on est en
échec et avec b6 on veut mettre le fou
en baisse est pour rajouter un contrôle
de la case de 4 donc par exemple le plan
blanc pour contrer c'est ce contrôle
noire des quatre centrales et des cases
blanches notamment ça peut être plus
tard de jouer f3 de façon contrôlée avec
un pion cette case et plus tard de jouer
4 alors on n'en est pas là mais ces
cavaliers
2 alors l'intérêt de rio doce que si on
oblige la part par exemple à troyes le
fou de s'échanger on peut reprendre des
cavaliers et on a un contrôleur de la
case et 4 x 6 alors voilà c'est une
autre idée de jouer des tours de jouer
b6 maintenant qu'on a mis le cavalier là
ce n'était pas obligé il ya d'autres
choix
eh bien on ne protège plus le pion c4
dont on l'attaqué
pourquoi pas ça oblige et blanc à réagir
donc la réaction se fait pas attendre à
3 l'idée est la suivante c'est que on
pose la question aux fous si le fou
s'échange on le remplace avantageusement
par un autre cavalier et en même temps
avec le food on défend le pion de ces
quatre avec le chou et voilà donc à 3
indirectement défendre pioncer 4 on
attaque une pièce il faut répondre donc
ici branche thème choisi de ne pas
finalement prendre mais de jouer fawcett
alors on peut se dire mais alors s'il
vient b4 et qui revient le set il a
perdu du temps ben oui et non c'est à
dire que notre côté on a obligé les
blancs quelque part à jouer cavalier e 2
qui c'est pas pareil que cabaye f3 et la
question sur le pion c4 se pose ici
toujours donc le temps perdu par les
noirs est compensée par les temps aussi
perdu et un développement rampant aussi
par les blancs donc on peut pas dire que
c'est équivalent d'abord joué vous et
c'est tout de suite donc cavale et g3
donc là par contre on voit avec la les
g3 que l'idée de base est toujours là
c'est à dire que bon on protège ses 4,7
fait maintenant le cavalier protège 4 et
le cavalier j'ai aussi protège 4 donc la
poussière au théâtre est tout à fait
jouable maintenant par les blancs et
s'explique le coup suivant des noirs des
cinq t5 puisque maintenant dont le dans
l'idée est la suivante si le pion c4
prend en d5 l'on reprend du pied en
concédant d'abord on peut échanger
d'abord on peut changer les fous et
ensuite on reprendra du pion en d5 et on
contrôle quatre ballons toujours
c'est prend on prend ça c'est normal
vous de le dire vous prendront la forme
prendra alors les mots avec le cavalier
pour éviter de se priver de la
possibilité de roquet puisque si le roi
prend bien sûr l'idée rauque et si la
tour prend et bien on ne pourra plus
faire le petit rock et le grand roque
est peu envisageable dans cette position
exactement voilà la raison pour laquelle
on prend du cavalier afin de se ménager
la possibilité de faire le petit rock il
faut pas avoir bougé ni la tournée le
roi pour pouvoir prétendre faire le
petit rock ça pose un tout petit
problème ce cavalier il déjà joué trois
fois mon ouverture il va devoir jouer
une quatrième fois pour permettre le
rock des blancs oui en définitive c'est
un développement qui est un petit peu
ralenti ce développement ralentissent
est vrai que c'est pas c'est un
développement hyper agressive de ce
point de vue on est d'accord donc ici
maintenant on prend des sec alors
reprendre des scènes très bien les noirs
maintenant control4 alors à noter quand
même que la disparition du fou ducasse
blanche ici mais affaibli fortement les
cases blanches on voit que les pions
sursaut cases noires bon maintenant les
blancs non plus non plus le foot case
blanche a plus que la dame pour pouvoir
vraiment attaquer ces cases on s'est
quand même sujet à noter aussi que les
blancs quand même un plan possible aussi
c'est de mettre des pièces sur la
colonne c'est pour faire pression ici ça
s'appelle nicolon semi ouverte parce
qu'il n'ya pas le pion blanc donc elle
est ouvert de ce côté là mais il ya un
tueur noir donc elle est semi ouverte et
ça peut être un thème de jeu que de
faire pression sur cette colonne c'est
pour les blancs c'est un thème classique
des parties du pion dame pour les blancs
puisque le pion c7 est relativement
affaibli voilà alors souvent les noirs
d'ailleurs d'anjou en c5 protégé par le
front protégé par le pion b61 cavalière
17 qui rajoute de la protection et c'est
un pion qui est actif ici puisqu'il est
à tout moment il peut s'échanger au
centre mais on ne va pas le laisser ans
et c'est tout effectivement c'est city
serait par contre sous pression on va
essayer de pousser donc on va faire
attention à des coups comme b4 parce que
beckham va essayer de rajouter de la
pression sur ses 5 et un échange après
deux pions laissera le pion desseigne
tout seul donc tous à dos calculé parce
que c'est pas en finale qu'il faut y
réfléchir c'est cette suite c'est trop
tard un final le pion aux olives à se
faire prendre et on va souffrir tout le
long de la partie donc avalé g3 d'amd
cette voie là alors à noter encore une
fois on le voit souvent des droits tv le
fou qui nous reste est sûre case noire
et la dame on l'a mise sur casse blanche
comme ça on a deux pièces qui contrôlent
des cases diagonale de couleurs
différentes
donc on contrôle les cases à la fois
noir et les cases blanches
donc ça c'est un thème quand on sait pas
quoi faire quand ce n'est pas en mettre
sa dame regarder si vous restez un fou
de la couleur la couleur du fou ça ça
aide souvent à savoir trouver une case
intéressante
alors on se prive de là on se prive de
la possibilité de cette case pour le
cavalier mais peut-être plus cavalier on
veut sortir par assises venir
être plus tard une fois qu'on a joué ses
singles dans l'hexagone on peut aussi
envisager qu a laissé six mois je sais
pas mais c'est pas c'est pas très gênant
bon à noter comme 17 aussi on veut
éviter qu'un médiatisation et vider des
caves et les f-5 est peut-être un
éventuel cavaliers b5 plus tard et
éventuellement pourquoi pas de calais b
sanou un échec par damas quatre qui
obligerait aussi et se déterminer moyens
aux cavaliers 1 dames à 4h et pourquoi
pas aussi exactement tout à fait bon en
voix rauque est aussi en hausse mais en
deçà des 3 qu'on veut on veut éviter les
scènes parce que si on rentre tout de
suite camille f5 et le fou est prenable
si on perd cela fout c'est comme ça peut
être embêtant quand même quand même un
fou de l'autre côté on a une position
avec une colonne semi mer ouverte contre
nous bon c'est pas c'est pas forcément
agréable donc d'un f3 bon c'est la
position générale c'est des
considérations générales nature tout ça
donc damev 3 alors là aussi à noter qu
adam et de la couleur opposée du fou
d'accord donc non mais froid pourquoi
pas développement de la dame elle vient
protéger la case f5 pour éventuellement
jouer ce coup de cavaliers avaient
clairement oui bien sûr on peut jouer on
peut envisager de jouer cavalier f5
maintenant puisque la dame et 3 protège
on a une petite pression pourquoi pas
aussi son dessin devance une pour
l'instant c'est bien défendu mais c'est
là et puis comme lecavalier pas de
caviar f3 finalement ou de la dame a
trouvé une belle quasi si elle est bien
elle agit sur le central agit dans le
camp ennemi
elle est pas vraiment on ne peut pas
vraiment la déloger de là c'est pas
facile à attaquer une dame ici où comme
en forêt il n'y a pas de casse d'attac
on a plus fougasse blanche on n'a pas de
cavalier qui pourrait advenir l'embêter
donc elle est bien placée cette dame aux
signes qu'avait laissé six de la part
des membres voient là donc finalement
choisi la casse et 6 un plan pour les
noirs peut être aussi maintenant de
jouer cavalier à 5 et pour envahir ont
gardé les cases blanches faible du côté
noir parce que du côté blanc pardon du
côté blanc ici on voit bien que les
pions sur noir le fou et de cases noires
est allé casf m pour sur lesquels on
pourra se positionner
donc on n'a pas peur de jouer le quart
nécessite tout de suite pour menacer sa
si les blancs jouent le coup
mais quatre c'est envisageable pour
empêcher car il ya 5 et contrôler la
casse est celle dont on a vu que ça
pouvait bien d'avoir des pions qui
contrôlent 6ème puisqu'on en plus ces
cinq c'est possible d'envisager ça c'est
pas la partie des quatre auraient été
tout à fait envisageable alors là
peut-être que les noirs peuvent
envisager des cons comme assise pour
contrôler les cases blanches et ensuite
cavalier à 7 et peut-être devenir / / b
ce genre de plan on peut céder après par
tour ses huit c5 pour essayer de casser
ça ou plus tard pourquoi pas de jouer
aussi à 5
il ya plein d'idées pour les noirs de ce
côté là si les blancs sont entre autres
aux actifs pour pouvoir créer du jeu
du côté dames et ne pas rester passif on
a parlé tout à l'heure d'aller retour du
fou noir qui avait qu'yves d'abord allé
en b 4 qui revient aux sept voiliers sap
a été en pure perte non plus puisque la
poussée du pion à 3 par les blancs a
affaibli quand même la casse b3
clairement voilà ça ça donne une pause
petite possibilité aux cavaliers voilà
les coups de pied on sent responsable
effectivement on a chassé le foot alors
mais on affaiblit une case blanche
bon ça peut être une thème ici on a vu
en l'an 2000 adams aux cases blanches
yann cavalli qui peut aller ils
demandent pourquoi pas petit rock
logique et là j 6 alors voilà bombe
évidemment on voit très vite maintenant
d'après ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
pour quoi j'ai si c'est bien contre les
cinq ans on veut éviter quand même un
bon cavalier un f5 c'est toujours
embêtant car il ya eu 5
je crois que c'est kasparov qui disait
qu'un cavalier m5 savoie un pion aux
cavaliers un f4 pour les noirs mais ici
c'est les blancs car il y avait 500 go 1
billion donc g6 alors attention ça
affaiblit un peu les classements mais
bon on a le fou en ahl fougueuse noir
donc c'est moins généralement sur la
ville passe ou ça serait quand même ça
pourrait être très embêtant et puis le
fou de
blanc de 15 mois et pour l'instant ne
peut pas vraiment agir faudrait pousser
eux quatre si on pousse eu 4 attention
inaction des quatre qui est faible il
est attaqué notamment par le cavalier
donc fou des deux faut pas se presser
connexion le fou est pas super bien
placé en d2 pour l'instant est par
contre on à connecter les tours donc
pourquoi pas envisager des coups comme
maintenant tours fc 1
les tours sont connectés pour ces deux
on double les tours sur la colonne sait
et on envisage une pression sur la
fameuse colonne celui ouverte alors la
colonne semi-ouverte là est un petit peu
ce qui est un petit peu ennuyeux pour
les noirs c'est qu'ils ont le pion 6,7
les cavaliers ans et 6 c'est toujours
embêtant d'avoir le cavalier devant le
pion ouais on puisque qui a bien pu le
plus on bessette pour défendre le
cavalier il ya que la dame et on voit
qu'effectivement un doublement des tours
poserait tout de suite question au noir
oui on pourrait imaginer après
d'ailleurs des dames f4 ici qui
rajouterait de la pression des choses
comme ça quoi que monia le fouillent
êtes vous là la foule quand même là en
défense on peut imaginer un peu fou d81
food et si on veut pas bouger ce pion on
peut quand même le protéger c'est pas
facile de quand même de de l'attaqué
clairement mais c'est quand même une
pression qui va falloir donc il va
falloir tenir compte si ça se déroule
comme ça petit rock
maintenant c'est l'heure aussi à noter
maintenant que ça y est les tours sont
connectés ah oui comme ses joueurs on
est à cette époque là on donc ont bien
fini leur développement
développer leur pièce fait le rock en
fait tous les fondamentaux sont bien ont
bien été résolus mais avec des
subtilités dans les coups on a line
alors là on qu intéressant de bobigny
calais co2
il enlève alors on si on comprend
combien de d'expliquer on comprend un
peu bien l'idée c'est que l'on joue
qu'un wc ou deux alors on peut faire
plein de choses
d'abord peut envisager de venir être
captées pourquoi pas plus tard
mais deux on allie commencé à libérer
cette colonne donc l'action des tours
sera plus clair et puis 3 pourquoi pas
on donne un peu d'air à ce fou qui se
retrouvent avec des possibilités de
jouer notamment ces trois notamment où
ils pourraient où il pourrait soutenir
la poussée de 4 puisque maintenant navré
de défenseurs du cul en d4 à savoir le
cavalier et le fou voilà pourquoi pas on
pourrait aussi efficace sur contrôler
des quatre pour pouvoir local non
seulement retrouvé à part à la fin avec
un pion ont peut-être un peu isolés ici
en d4
un petit peu isolé mais avec quand même
des pressions fortes notamment parce que
la diagonale de la dame peut s'ouvrir
sur ces 6 s'il ya eu une préparation
avec tours etc c'est un par exemple
l'attentât fait
un beau travail il faut en tenir compte
exactement pression tout cas si les
noirs font rien ils vont laisser tous
les blancs augmenter les pressions sur
tous les côtés on peut très bien doubler
les tours puis pourquoi pas envisager
des fous ces trois des quatre et
d'ouvrir totalement le jeu avec une
pression qui peut s'avérer favorable aux
blancs donc il faut pas avec les noirs
rester les bras ballants donc brancher à
une belle prend son destin en main il
joue h5 donc acheté un coup actifs alors
c'est intéressant puisqu'on voit quand
même qu'ici que bon ben on a un cavale
et j3 qui va pouvoir être chassé
d'ailleurs ouvert cavaliers tout de
suite si les blancs ne font rien mais il
sera obligé d'aller sur une case
quand même bon ne sera pas superlatifs
s'il est obligé d'aller aux régions il
va falloir réagir donc s'explique le
coup suivant tours fc 1-2 voilà c'est
logique tours fc
on envisage de mettre le cavalier en f1
en cas de poussée ce sera un cabinet
défensif bien placé les noirs ont pris
l'espace à la loi donc ils se retrouvent
un peu actif de ce côté là pourquoi pas
et les blancs au vont essayer
d'augmenter la pression elle dame alors
à noter que dans cette manoeuvre si ça
se déroule comme ça la dame f3 pas
forcément bien placé maintenant parce
que si les noirs ont décidé d'attaquer y
compris avec les pions et alba elle va
permettre cette position ici va
permettre au moins de gagner du temps en
poussant les pions dans les pionts
obligeant la dame la semaine sur une
case un peu inconfortable
voilà et n'ont pas peur ici de pousser
les pions du côté roy puisque finalement
il s'estime suffisamment bien protégé ya
pas vraiment de pièces agressive de ce
côté là et les blancs finalement on
envie de garder cette structure de pions
solide mais du coup ça veut dire qu'ils
renoncent attaque et de ce côté il veut
regardez d'ailleurs la structure de
pionsat aussi c'est un thème la
structure aucun leur garde de ce côté là
elle pousse de ce côté là donc on voit
bien que c'est ici le jeu finalement des
blancs donc il faut que les noirs et
agissent à l'élan puis les noirs peuvent
très bien jouer roi g7 et
tourtoirac g8 voilà un autre thème
changeons exactement c'est toujours les
scènes après avoir joué h 4 est de jouer
le tour h8 aussi pourquoi pas affaiblir
le camp blanc jouer dh 3 aussi affaiblir
les cases blanches faire ce genre
d'idées donc h4 c'est logique on n'a pas
ce pion on peut vraiment tout seul
puisqu'il ya le fou en transparence ici
qui le protège
il n'y a pas de problème de ce côté là
et puis c'est très difficile pour les
blancs d'aller chercher des attaques ici
n'ont pas de pièces en attaque il ya
beaucoup
la dame pour attac de ce côté là le fou
aussi le cavalier si c'est bien placée
en moi j'essaie de suivre tourache huit
tours h 50 ou le monter des pièces
attention câble et blanc sont pas comme
pas de raison d'être extrêmement ici non
plus ne seront rares et bien protégé il
ya du matériel est là après ce coup
maintenant quand même on voit mieux
l'idée de bretagne puisque h4 tac
et comme on l'avait dit on à fouet et
dames et puis on a le cavalier si ce qui
est quand même là et on peut jouer qu'à
lieu 4 donc invasion attaque tout de
suite le fou des deux ce qui peut être
un thème peut-être envie tout
alors pour l'instant il est mauvais ce
foot si derrière ses pions mais il est
quand même une pression et puis on
attaque surtout f2 on peut imaginer que
un plan roi g7 s'est un peu lent mais
pourquoi pas tous rage suite aux orages
5 et hop avec pression sur f2 c'est long
mais c'est jouable donc si a rien en
face ça peut faire mal et puis l'autre
pions j'ai peu poussé j'essaye chez 4 on
peut a derrière maintenant qu'on a sorti
le cavalier jouer f5 donc une marée de
pions peut se pousser une autre idée
aussi pour les noirs c'est classique d
des stratégies d'attaqué des noirs comme
ça dans une position ferme et c'est de
jouer tour eiffe sept tours à en fuite
et puis à tours et sète peut venir après
angers 7 et peut aider ses pions à aller
poussée et venir casser le roc blanc
donc attention cavalière 4 de bobigny
qui si dans cette position alors
peut-être qui il aurait pu commencer
quand même essayer de doubler les tours
puisqu'il ya une tour qui joue pas ici
notre bon il vient f4 alors qu'est ce
qu'ils viennent faire un f4 et bien par
un choix presque il vient et ce qu'il
pense à passer par trois pour sierra
envahir à un moment la case aux cinq
quitte à sacrifier une qualité voilà il
peut exactement ils peuvent venir
pourquoi pas elle même peut venir ici il
peut envisager aussi peut-être sur sur
g5 de mettre son cavalier hcm pourquoi
pas été décidé comme ça même si on n'a
pas trop envie dans le cailly comme ça
parce qu'on sait pas trop sait pas trop
comment ils réagissent à rentrer mais on
sait pas trop comment ils se voient là
on sait pas trop comment il sortira pris
toutes les cases de sortie sont prises
donc il avait choisi kf4 bon il peut
plus revenir hanter trois réguliers sur
c'est pour replacer dans cahier séries
dans l'est de l'île très passif en d3 et
ce sera un peu mieux puisqu'ils contre
la c5 on a vu que cette case pour une
importante pour éviter ces cinq
ultérieure des noirs et pourquoi pas la
fameuse 15,5 aussi bien sûr parce que si
si on arrive à jo qui avait cinq ça peut
être
il peut y avoir des choses donc ici à 5
de la part des noirs alors un coup
maintenant allèles dame mais à cinq ce
jour on le voit contre l'idée de b4
maintenant que les tours sont connectés
bien sûr l'idée b4 était dans l'air
encore plus est sûre à 5 les biens
en compteront sur contrôler la case b4
contrôlée par le cavalier et par le feu
voilà on essaie de l'en empêcher les
velléités
des invasions blanche du côté de la dame
jusqu'après b4 pourrez suivre b5 et les
pressions sur le cavalier qui révèlerait
actuellement la faiblesse du psion ses
sept exactement crb quatre baies 5
attaques lecavalier qui avait les
bouches à 4 et avec le bessin qu'on
empêche le pion c7 de bouger c'est à
dire qu'on contrôle la casse et 6 et ça
y est il y aura une pression terrible
qui va s'établir donc là on empêche
cette possibilité pour ces deux donc là
c'est le plan qu'on avait dit on va
doubler les tours et là nous allons
regarder bon toujours prophylactique la
prophylaxie et la food & vite on protège
le pion c7 avant que la taxe ne se fasse
puisque maintenant qu'à data qu'on peut
sortir le cavalier et c7 est protégé il
fallait parce qu'on ne peut pas tout
faire on peut pas il faut protéger comme
un but comme ça s'avère un petit peu
étrange de jouer ils sont fous en des 8
mai et de couper la connexion entre les
deux tours on n'a pas le temps de jouer
d'abord tours 8
et après
food et 8 sinon on va se faire attaquer
le cavalier oui parce que là il ya déjà
tour ces deux qui a été jouée tour suis
heureux si on joue tous s'y ajoutent
aurait vite 8 pouces attaque on ne peut
pas défendre le cavalier il bouge et on
perd c'est cette voie avec attac de la
dame initial d accès quasiment forcé
donc food et 8 est un coup quasiment
forcé tour alors fou alors voilà on voit
qui se presse pas il joue d'abord fou
hein alors fou un d'abord un sa protégée
2 c'est pas si mal
2 c'est pas négligeable aussi la tour
c'est de contrôler la seconde rangée ça
peut aider à contrer des éventuelles
attaques des noirs sur le seul endroit
typique des attaques blanche allèles dan
ont à la fois on a une tour attaquante
et une tour défense il
et puis donc on s'est vite la
possibilité pour les noirs de prendre à
tout moment le fou des deux mais non
c'est une possibilité pour noir - la
possibilité pour l'adversaire mieux ces
essais on prépare peut-être aussi la
sortie du cavalier f1 on peut envisager
pour l'instant je joue quand même moins
que lecavalier 4 des noirs c'est vrai on
peut aussi envisager la sortie du
cavalier f1 en d2 pourquoi pas et voilà
donc en tout cas c'est un coup utile et
on va doubler les tours à noter
d'ailleurs que c'est mieux pour les
blancs de faire ça et de doubler
puisqu'on à connecter les tours alors
que là on voit qu'on a des tournants
connectés mais les noirs ont ceci de
particulier qu'ils ont quand même une
emprise sur les dames qu'ils ont bien
géré avec une pression sur ce côté là et
aussi une emprise sur un droit c'est
risqué de la part d'orange taille mais
il a pu le faire parce que le sens très
bien
bien dérouillé j'espère qu'il le sentait
pas mobile si le centre avait t mobile
c'est très dangereux comme ça de
s'affaiblir sur les ailes avec après
bien des possibilités la taxe des deux
côtés des risques de pertes matérielles
fort cavaliers 7
il n'attend pas le doublement des
tourelles branche états unis six
cavaliers 7
alors on voit très vite que ce cas ils
peuvent redevenir actif d'écouté rejoint
là aussi enlève scène pourquoi pas ou
après une poussée g5y peut venir
s'installer manger 6 voilà après une
poussée g5 qui chasserait de carrière 4
on peut venir j 6 aussi tout à fait
d'amd dans me2 donc re recul de bobigny
que maintenant en e2 pourquoi pas
envisager f3 possible pour chasser le
cavalier et en plus à noter que f3
chasse lecavalier et activent le fou un
sur le petit pion s4 c'était peut-être
aussi dans l'idée donc cavalier d66 et
c'est fou comme ils préviennent les
menaces a manqué l'elysée dans la
prophylaxie laquelle elle si ses ongles
avec trois tables dans le vide mais
n'ont pas tout à fait ça tu as cru quand
même h4 mais on a le temps de défendre
il le fait d'ailleurs alors le problème
de f3 davantage c'est que f3 donc au
moins tout contrôle maintenant le cadre
donc on a repoussé en repoussent les
pièces et le fou un attaque h4 là il est
vraiment prise il va falloir qu'elle
trie faire quelque chose il suffit soit
de jouer g5 et le cavalier bouger on a
protégé soit de bouger ce cavalier et
c'est le fou
les huit qui protégerait à noter que ce
fou les miens quand même protège des
pions importants
donc j'ai 5 bon ça c'est la deuxième
option est là alors évidemment que ce
que ce qu'on a mis sous terre c'est que
si on vient là pourquoi pas c'est
envisageable mais on n'a pas de casse de
sortie après c'est à dire que là on
n'ait pris toutes les cases sont prises
suffit de protéger cette case suffit pas
dames 2 6 août un f5 aux menaces danger
si c'est le cas les prix ça obligerait à
affaiblir le camp est notre quinze jours
j'ai quatre des choses comme ça ça
serait ça pourrait être s'avérer
extrêmement dangereux donc il faut pas
venir comme ça dans deux ans et demi si
on n'a pas les idées extrêmement clair
et puis du soutien il faut du soutien
donc calé détroit c'est d'autant plus
logique de fauqa un des trois que la
case de 5 est affaiblie et la menace
c'est qu'il ya cinq attaques la dame
avec ankama et même place et donc d'un
racisme ont aussi sonné vente encore oui
encore une fois c'est qu'on joue le coup
avant qu'il soit en que la menace arrive
maintenant sur cac valeo 5 on peut
envisager des pompes comme f6 chasse le
cavaliere son tour on n'a pas peur
encore une fois de pousser les coûts les
pions du côté roy puisque les noirs ont
envie d'attaquer du côté du côté rang
ils ont en plus maintenant que f3 était
joué la diagonale de la dame est bouché
il n'y a pas de on voit pas de d'attac
direct sur la structure de pions il n'y
a pas de contre attaque d'un camp noir
mais même il ya tellement de pièces de
toutes façons un coup après comme
touriste est et puis ça y est en
coulisses sur la seconde avec une une
marée de pion à soutenir donc c'est à 4
maintenant de la part de bobigny alors à
4 alors l'intérêt de la halle 4 mai
ainsi que évidemment emballée ces
contrôles la casse b5
déjà on immobilise aussi la phalange de
pions y 6 au 15 mois
c'est la couleur de notre fou c'est bien
pour l'attack le coup l'intérêt du coup
à 4 aussi centre en fixant le pion à 5
c'est d'envisager la forte poussée b400
permettre aux noirs de jouer 1,4 voilà
on évite la pousser à 4 des noirs ce que
là on va être obligé de prendre
et dans ce cas là ça va activer
fortement le fou sur ce fou qui pour
l'instant été un peu passif pas se
retrouver actifs en mai 4 avec plein de
pièces à ramasser plein des chances
possibles à tout moment une fois actif
alors que jusqu'ici ils étaient pris
derrière ses pions donc voilà l'idée on
fixe d'abord les pions avant de faire la
poussée on peut pas empêcher les
nordiques et attend maintenant c'est
fini
donc qu'elle valait g6 mont sutton c'est
pareil continue son plan maintenant
puisque cavalli g6 bombay il réveille
son fou en termes d'action ici ce
cavalier commencent aussi à être actif
il compte de contrôle des classes
notamment il n'empêche que radio 5
et puis on a libéré surtout la colonne
eux parce que les blancs jouent en f3 en
affaiblit leur pion de 3 donc on va
pouvoir doubler ici
et puis commencer à faire pression sur 3
pourquoi pas après un long cavalier f5
qui rajoute de la pression et manas
gagner un pion donc c'est c'est toujours
pareil c'est des combos champions ont
créé potentiellement des menaces sur
d'autres des faiblesses sur sur le pion
à côté quoi oui si on exprime iii est
faible c'est pas parce qu'il est pas
protégé il est protégé deux fois par la
dame et le cavalier wii est faible parce
qu'il n'ya pas de pions qui puisse le
défendre là où il est il faut
immobiliser des pièces à sa défense donc
c'est des pièces qui peuvent pas
participer à la pac ailleurs doivent
rester en défense et si les noirs
augmente la pression il faudra peut-être
trouvé une autre pièce en défense
peut-être le roi mais si on amène le roi
ici assez dangereux c'est dangereux il
est plus proche de se faire prendre des
échecs ici il est vraisemblable que les
noirs ont aussi en projet de jouer f5
pour fixer cette faiblesse parce que
l'une des façons de se débarrasser de ce
puits en femme se serait de finaliser le
pousser au cap dont on parle depuis tout
à l'heure
après vingt cinq ce serait très
compliqué mais là ça devient impossible
il aurait des échanges par tous les
noirs contre très bien la case le cas
tout à fait oui elle 5 c dans l'idée
c'est on n'a pas peur de pousser les
pions devant le royal et beaucoup de
pièces en défense devant le moins
innovant et très bien protégé
donc si ses pions son équipe en attaque
on est d'accord donc h3 d'ailleurs un
labo de binic encore une fois ici veut
empêcher aussi des g4 ultérieure si on
joue f5 non seulement on immobilise 3
mais on peut pousser g4 avec un froid
c'est plus dur et aussi on se ménagent
la possibilité pour les blancs de jouer
cavalier h2k les g4 ont pour effet
d'activer ce cavalier un peu un peu il
me
lisez alors c'était peut-être temps pour
les blancs de commencer à jouer
b4 ici parce que ce coût à trois quand
même c'est un coût qui affaiblit les
cases noircies l'école soir sont plus
affaibli le se fout là maintenant ça
devient plus délicate où les cas
d'ailleurs parce que si on éloigne le
foule à l'aide
mais ce classement un peu un peu seul
donc h3 f5
voilà c'est l'idée on verrouille le 4 on
immobilise ce pion on va pouvoir
pourquoi pas doubler les tours alors
peut-être au lieu de cela on aimerait
bien mettre l'autre pour l'instant mais
on ne peut pas il ya le fou hein mais on
peut jouer aussi des tours et sète pour
protéger là on peut envisager défaut et
si on remet la thau et hop on remet le
feu à des voitures arrivent 7 serait
très utile au tours fc est toujours
utile parce qu'après ça permet aux sites
au fcn voyez devenir angers 7 et angers
cette dernière un peu aidé par la
poussée g4 d'or à la tour de main et
puis derrière alors voir donc ça s'est
toujours bien pousser 3 alors là un coup
bas
intéressant de bobigny quand même ici
parce que leur l'idée de bobigny qu'il
renonce à jouer beckham pour l'instant
est sûre contrôler la case 2,5 cirque il
a vu que son pion de trois étaient sur
colonne de pression en contrôlant la
case 5 et il peut verrouiller en jouant
cavalier 5 qui joue cavalier 5 et il a
bouché
7 cette colonne mais il ya des échanges
possibles mais c'est pas si simple donc
faux et 6 alors là par contre évidemment
le problème de fous ces trois c'est bien
ça contre le 5 mai ça laisse le temps
et oui parce qu'on a perdu ses sept ans
venant laon sur contrôle e5 donc
finalement la menace comme le sel n'est
plus là et puis on menace d'activer la
tour qui jouait pas cher maintenant dans
cette tour peut venir à 8 et une fois
qu'on a mis la tour en huit si on rejoue
food est vite plus tard et bien toutes
les pièces noires sont actives au centre
vers des droits tandis que les blancs
n'ont toujours pas passé du côté dames
donc il semblerait que la déjà la
pression commence à être en faveur de
branch times que maud vinik à force de
différer finalement ses plans et puis
d'essayer de d'empêcher toute avancée à
gauche et à droite et il n'y a pas pris
de décision et
il se retrouve à être de plus en plus
étouffée finalement il a un peu laissé
l'initiative au noir dans une position
bronstein a éventé toutes les toutes les
menaces ont elles pouvoir activer ces
pièces oui oui parce que là on voit bien
la menace là et puis ils ont bouché leur
attaque ici faudrait presque réactiver
cette menace il faudra prises pour
rejouer fouet
mais non il fait tourner autour alors là
c'est là alors c'est là qu'on voit que
body nicolas il ajoute rien
oui parce que l'idée de fond de tous son
plan c'était de doubler les tours sur la
colonne c'est oui là il montre qu'il y
renonce
mais your own aussi dénis surprotège de
trois ans alors qu'il se met en position
passive sarlat le champion le champion
du monde ici se met en position passive
il a renoncé aux attaques allèles dame
donc finalement il donne à voir raisons
internes style certes il lui dit -
finalement ton plan de décines empêché
de faire quoi que ce soit de ce côté là
a marché et c'est vrai j'admets que
c'est wasquehal initiative à la fois à
tous mais pression sur le centre et en
plus tu menaces des poussées des g4 des
poussées du côté de l'ex-roi et donc je
me mets en défense y manquer il est en
position déjà extrêmement défensive 3,8
et voilà c'est une idée qu'on avait dit
c'est que si on avait ri si on
réussissait à l'isf ou bien qu'on arrive
à activer la tour ça et toutes les
pièces noires sont hyper active
hyper-active pression sur le centre
maximale pression sur la colonie on
pourra envisager des tours et vii et
pourquoi pas tous recettes trois pièces
lourdes contre 3 c'est grave c'est ça
commence à être très grave ça commençait
très grave parce qu'après les
possibilités de 4,2 tactique arrive
c'est vrai on va pouvoir jouer f4 par
exemple et on peut pas jouer quatre donc
on va c'est obligé de lâcher le qe3 très
dur
tu rêves 4 on peut ramener le cahier des
six temps f5 ça fait peur et ça fait
très peur les possibilités des noirs
sont très très nombreuses dans le dos
alors ça c'est pas mal c'est un bon coup
défensif d'âme des uns l'idée c'est que
maintenant les scènes fise avitour dames
c'est toujours désagréable
on n'a pas envie d'avoir une tour en
face et en plus on peut envisager de
doubler les tours donc on crée une
contrebasse via les tour c'est mieux que
d'avoir la dame devant puisque la dame
est toujours une pièce qu'on n'a pas
envie de se faire prendre
ici sur une batterie il vaut mieux la
plupart du temps à voir les pièces les
plus aimés - forment devant les plus
légères exactement les pieds se tournent
plus loin derrière donc tous rêvent
cette part là c'est l'idée qu'on avait
dit alors l'intérêt de tous rêvent
peut-être les multiples jeux contrôler
ses sets je peux glisser éventuellement
g7 pour et des réponses et g4 et je peux
aussi me mettre sur la colonne eux pour
augmenter la pression sur trois donc
c'est tout restait extrêmement mobile et
elle est extrêmement complémentaires
avec sa collègue en 8 donc là les pièces
noires sont alors quasi maximum de
potentiel donc ça veut dire qu'on
approche du moment où la combinaison va
prendre le pas sur le positionne elle
sur la le combat professionnel est en
faveur de branches times clairement ici
voyez là le dynamisme des pièces noires
des pièces noires sur le camp blanc la
force qu'elle exerce toutes ces pièces
sur le camp blanc alors que les pièces
blanches ne sont pas en position de
créer des menaces d'un canon arrière il
n'y a quasiment aucune pièce blanche qui
attaquent quoi que ce soit sacré en fait
il ya pas de point d'entrée dans
l'opposition il n'y a rien il n'y a
aucun point d'entrée en prononçant dans
ces puits sont blanches est totalement
pas si vous voyez comme la maestria
positionnelle bernstein puis le style de
l'époque inquiété avant tout positionné
et pas et pas tactique donc b3 alors là
c'est vraiment le coup alors b3 l'idée
de b3 peut être de reculer le fou ces
trois par exemple pourquoi pas en voir
un b2 et afin de libérer un peu une
action sur le camp noir mais on l'a vu
c'est pas très grave puisqu'on peut
jouer ou des huit de toute façon sans
compter que la tour eiffel sete protège
déjà mais ça peut être l'idée que ce fou
de caleçons noirs ici finalement bloque
la tour et on veut garder le contrôle
sur la case 2 5gt apparemment il veut
garder ce contrôle non mais
vraisemblables aussi que votre unique
n'a pas du tout envie de voir le
cavalier noir en c4 c'est vrai aussi la
menace noir était aussi devenir ans et 4
on est d'accord c'est vrai puisque ans
et 4 on rajouter une pression pardon ici
mais sur le pion de 3 bon ceci il y
avait la dame ici c'est un peu un peu
délicat puisque la dame qui protège
c'est pas terrible en mai sur mais sera
peut-être permis de jouer ensuite thème
des six exact et puis c'est vrai que
c'est en gardant des 600 mises en liga
cement en plus du côté ça peut être
embêtant et la tour est ce cette vraie
c'est ce qu'on avait dit ils avaient le
choix et bill appris ça y est il a
augmenté la pression
il va sans doute après enlever sa dame
en fait par exemple ont des cp ou
pousser s'il s'avère que c'est possible
d'ailleurs après foulée deux abaissé
leur déjà fou b2 alors faut bd est
intéressant puisque four b2 évidemment
bon ben je libère un peu d'action ici
c'est à dire que si ces pièces allaient
prendre que trois plus tard avait on
pourra se venger sur le pion ses 7es
mais là c'est l'heure pour les noirs de
faire des choix finaux seller de de
prendre ses responsabilités maintenant
que la tension est au maximum quoi faire
avec les noirs on peut envisager alors
de jouer damev sept ans laissant même
dans les tours l'attaquent ici on ne
peut envisager de juger quatre peut
commencer à faire des bulles de
de briser mais non il choisit un coût
plus tendues encore manche times f4
alors un coup un coût extrêmement tendue
puisque il est extrêmement responsable
c'est peut-être un peu tôt parce qu'on
se dit mais attention on peut prendre
qu'est ce qui se passe sur pions prend
s4 eh ben c'est simple les noirs ont
décidé sans doute deux sacrifiés
peut-être leur leur dan en faisant d'en
prendre pour un carrément alors c'est un
pseudo sacrifice puisqu'après cavale et
prendre tout on a tout reprend et on a
déjà deux pièces tour et cavaliers
contre la dame ce qui est déjà beaucoup
parce que vous savez en terme de points
tour violées et fait 8
donc c'est presque la dame et en plus on
a une position écrasante cercla il faut
bouger la dame parce qu'elle est
attaquée par exemple pour joindre des
trois c'est bien parce qu'on attaque le
cavaly g6 mais justement cavaliers 108 4
à seller de calais point f carte et on
réattaque la dame et avait tout ça est
quand même extrêmement délicat il y en a
une qualité extrêmement puissant sur g2
souffou ne joue pas les deux tours sont
hyper active où va la dame
on peut même pas rester sur les cases
blanches donc sans doute ensuite ce
cavalier va venir henri iv alors gardons
ici on trouvait un peu une variante par
exemple d'am dam à 6 et tout de suite
qui avait valu cinq avec la menace
cavaliers g3 avec la menace cavalli g3
qui menace tout reprend enfin suivi du
mat fashion on peut rien faire en fait
c'est à dire que là que je voulais blanc
contrecarrer g3 remet il ya pas de coût
et à tourtour f2 alors si on joue ton
rêve de on a un beau sacrifice je pense
avec tours 8 8,2 on peut envisager non
on est étonné à
attention voilà mais on peut envisager
simplement câble et g3 que font que font
les blancs cavale et g3 la menace c'est
de jouer cavalier deux échecs le roi
bouge et on perd le
le câblier f1 sur échec sur échec sur
échec donc ces voiliers comme le roi le
roi blanc est totalement en prison ici
c'est un quasi matin que font les que
font les blancs c'est mort alors si on
essaie de jouer rouages devant dijon
cavaliers prendre tout reprendre tout
reprend il ya de la dame ici qui protège
et c'est maintenant qu'on peut jouer ton
8e de 8,2 alors ton 8e nous regarder
maintenant surtout reprendre le dos qui
le seul coup aux tensions puisque on
menace de gagner une tour donc il faut
prendre la tour mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec tourcoing f1 tout par une
femme menace matt essai imparable je
crois pas qu'on puisse faire grand chose
si on fait échec
il suffit du leroy f cette attaque la
tour et il ya toujours une menace de
maths
donc il faudrait prendre la tour et la
dame cavalli prendre et chez coran et
enfin deux variantes comprend la tour et
même si on perd le cap fm on a une pièce
de plus donc la combinaison est tout à
fait valable
c'est énorme donc en fait fou après fou
b2f 4 en fait bronstein est calculée
sacrifice de damas femme seule au
sacrifice pour contours et cavaliers et
une position écrasante avec une grosse
attraction leroy imparable et l'avoir
parce que c'est pas évident comme ça
s'est fait refouler pas évidente mais on
voit bien que va moins vite que ça
écrase cohen oui
d'où la réponse de vote unique qui ne
peut pas se permettre de prendre la
bonne voie qu'il a peur un fait et ça me
fait peur et ça y est finalement il joue
son coût pour lequel il avait joué
toutes ces mêmes de fous un peu
extrêmement passive mais le cavalier 1,5
alors qu'elle est l'espoir de votre vie
nikki six ans jean cavalier 5 c'est de
soulager la pression énorme mais en
faisant des échanges de pièces parce
qu'il donne un pion parce que ici on
peut prendre et il ya quand même un deux
trois pièces à l'attack ici contre à
peine deux défenseurs le pion des 4 et
le fou donc on perd de toute façon on va
perdre quelque chose donc ici d'ailleurs
fou prend 2,5 à noter d'ailleurs qu'il
donne le fou et non pas le cavalier ici
c'est à dire qu'il estime que dans cette
position les cavaliers pouvant sauter
sur les cases notamment g3 notamment de
trois sont plus puissants que sont fous
il préfère donner le
des prendre 5 est très joli derrière
cavaliere cette magnifique c'est superbe
alors laquelle il se presse pas il au
quatrième set il veut pouvoir prendre f4
pardon cinq ici avec un cavalier à noter
que la prise ici que fait mode unique
est quasiment la seule possible qu'elle
est ici prend 2 points 4 se heurtent
trouve très simple câble et point f4
voilà pourquoi ils ont que semble
apprécier ici de reprendre il ya le foot
n'est sûr qu'ils protègent sont pas
pressés de reprendre si les noirs parce
qu'ils veulent jouer sans doute à 9,5
et puis ensuite reprendre avec
lecavalier
oui ce serait ce serait une erreur de
vouloir prendre trop vite le pion oui
cavaliers prend 1,5 à créer un clouage
en fait sur sur la dame
oui voilà on veut simplement on pourrait
prendre de la tour puisqu'on est protégé
du fou et on va pas prendre quand même
la dame ici dans cette position c'est
pas la même que tout à l'heure il n'y a
plus autant de pièces à l'attack donc
non non on va pas se presser pour
reprendre et surtout ce cavalier était
donc on l'avait dit tout à l'heure un
cavalier en f4 f5 c'est énorme pression
ici pression sur toutes les cases du
camp et puis on voit on peut même on
peut pas chasser ce cavalier ses terres
qu'il a une case ici n délogeables elle
et blanc peuvent pas juger trop à cause
du pion h 15 donc on voit que la
faiblesse ici qu'on a créé sur les cases
noires ne vous aide pas
dans ce type de configuration donc la bo
de vigny que ces deux voit bien qu'il
est là et qu'il est un peu saucissonné
il est un peu saucissonné si bien sûr si
en plus ce n'est pas que ça circule et
noir peuvent jouer ces cinq des quatre
avec une phalange de pions qui avancent
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui va se passer et
puis tu as pris car les âges de hockey
l'un des rares coups possibles c5 les
blancs les noirs pendant vont pas jouer
dame f5 tout de suite parce que ils
veulent pas laisser le pion des cinq
hommes sans protection non plus pourquoi
que quelqu'un protège mais ils veulent
aussi augmenté leur pression c'est celle
on peut plus empêcher des 4 et des cas
tu le fou voilà pour couper le food de
la protection du pion un pion de fous ne
joue plus il est mort déjà qu'il n'a pas
joué du tout dans la partie alors même
le jour où il extrait mais un tout petit
peu il est tout fait ces cinq
la pression est énorme bobigny qui joue
un des rares coups possibles là encore
il essayé d'activer son cavalier il y
avait 4 il est pas mal ce cavalier bon
il commence à avoir un petit peu lherm
on se dit qu'il ya la case f6 est une
sphère fait être un échec ce genre de
choses otage le pion sans qu on protège
le pion aux cinq bons des quatre étouffe
et tout fait et tout fait votre mini
après des quatre évidemment la menace ça
peut être d'amd 5 ou alors pas d'un des
cinq peut-être le chevalier les scénic
ou et venturi valider cinq pour un
éventuel cavale de trois par exemple
ensuite on va pas c'est possible ou d'un
mètre 5 plutôt on va jouer damev sec
une fois qu'on a joué dans les cinq on a
libéré l'action des tours sur la colonne
eux
et puis on va prendre tranquillement le
pion de 500 après une prise échange on
gagne la colonne eux ont une position
écrasante puisque à la fois en un pion
passé lié au centre très proche de la
promotion
on contrôle la colonie
on a un travail à l'attaquant f4 à la
position est morte et bientôt peut-être
un deuxième qui ont passé liées puisque
ce coût des quatre menaces de trial
d'hommes prend b3 c'est exactement là on
y va permettre qui permettra alors là au
noir d'avoir une poussée de pions elle
est loin de là du coup on a un an
d'option pas c'est énorme on n'aurait
même pas peur de cavaliers échec
on va prendre cavalli prendre tour on
perdrait la qualité mais en échange de
quoi en un ici les pions qui vont
quasiment adam tout seul sans effort bon
ceci dit on n'est même pas obligé de
donner la qualité la position est
écrasant de la menace votre vie n'excède
un f5
on n'a pas peur de karachi c'est un
cavalier c'est ici de toute façon y'a
pas de fourchette donc à olive cinq rois
g7 au roi h7 même on va jouer hanche et
on va se protéger d'éventuels échecs on
n'est même pas pressés parce que les
noms et les plantes peuvent rien faire
je peux même pas doubler les tons jem
qualificatives empêche jéhovah la dalle
on peut pas venir en d3 on peut rien
faire on peut jouer que du coup
d'attentes en fait donc c'est une
torture et la beauté unique craque
il tente une dernière chose mais c'est
une grosse erreur en fait on ne
considère il joue simplement khalef six
échecs ça a l'air d'être bien puisque ça
fait une fourchette échec tour ce
meeting à fos une gamme et le côté
qu'est ce qui peut faire et le potentiel
problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas de coupes
dans cette position on veut le voir que
fait on ne peut pas doubler car il prend
on peut pas on pourrait faire quoi dans
des deux cc d'amd de l empêche pas de f5
empêche pas de consolider la position
peu jours c'est 3g 6 pourquoi pas rien
ne presse pour prendre le kiosque le
jour on le prend c'est une invasion noir
par la colonne eux par le pion des qui
va avancer en d3 puis ont des doutes qui
va fermer ils sont totalement vie c'est
bon ils tentent encore qu'alexis mais
simplement dame preuve six abandons
puisque après
le fort ses pions prendra simplement
tout reprend échec et donc la dame est
rendu tout de suite avec donc une
tournette de plus une pièce d'être de
plus en cabine de plus c'est toujours
une pulsion écrasante avec les pions
passé ici au centre
donc c'est un écrasement positionner
cette partie qui est typique je crois
qu'on peut lire du stylo gauche times
quoi oui oui un style très positionnelle
et puis pas quand les conditions sont
mûres forcément il ya des possibilités
tactiques qui s'ouvre qui secret est
presque naturellement presque
naturellement il a n'a pas vraiment
cherché à faire un feu d'artifice
tactique
les choses se sont présentés presque
presque d'elle même la position s'est
écroulé d'elle même en fait on fur à
mesure qu'ils augmenter sa pression sur
le centre etc
il a découragé votre unique de tenter
une ouverture à l'aller lé dann en fait
son coût à 5 finalement été oui
apparemment très fort à s'inquiéter très
fort h32 vini qui était peut-être pas le
meilleur coût et ce moment là oui c'est
à dire que effectivement quand un beau
de binic jouent alors fait plus haut
qu'elle a fait l'endroit c'était on peut
revenir juste à sept points voilà ici
qu'en mode vinik jouent alors c'est le
coût d'un à quatre est compréhensible de
votre vie ni qu'on l'avait dit ça fixe
et après calais g6 et h3 alors là on se
dit non il y aurait sans doute fallu
tenter b4y quatre là il faut essayer
d'être actif faut plus c'est d'être
passif commune un communiqué il faut se
donner de l'air il faut créer des
contrôles menace du côté du côté dames
donc sans doute b4 et en cas de prise
pris soin du cavalier seul du fou avec
un peu de jeu au moins la possibilité
d'échanger ce fou pourquoi pas puisqu'il
n'est pas très actif et au moins
chercher chercher le secours dans une
finale ou même si on perd un pion peut
que tenter
d'avoir de l'activité pour compenser
finalement il a choisi de se laisser
écraser un positionnement par à petit
feu voilà une belle position finale à un
typique de la de la partie dans cette
position voilà avec une invasion finale
des noirs par la colonne de la pression
fini par faire craquer le camp blanc
belle partie est beau joueur que ce
david bronstein qui a quand même marqué
l'histoire du jeu d'échecs après guerre
et même bien plus tard il a il reste
actif toute sa vie jusqu'à la fin oui
resté très actif il est aimant récemment
on l'a encore dit donc il ya toute une
oeuvre il ya tout
on l'a dit avec les livres il ya aussi
beaucoup de parties qu'on vous invite à
regarder
voilà david bronstein donc pour
apprendre le jeu pulsionnel c'est c'est
le m merci de nous avoir suivis pour
cette émission puis vous donne rendez
vous pour un autre épisode de diagonale
tv dans cette série des grands champions
au revoir au revoir